Okay, so did you know that doodling is truly good for your brain?
Harvard Medical School did a study.
These are my favorite markers to doodle with
because they come in like a neat little carrying case
and it comes with a bajillion colors
and they have a broad side and a fine tip.
But doodling can help, like,
release some of the extra,
like, psychological stress in your brain.
Cause your brain wants to make sense of things.
It wants to everything to kinda line up and make sense,
but that's not how life necessarily works.
And so doodling can sometimes help your brain fill those gaps somehow.
Like they've done studies with EEG's.
I don't know, it's really interesting.
So I hope you doodle some more in your life.
These markers are linked right here. If you want to set